[Music]
anime has long been known for its
amazingly animated
memorable and simply breathtaking fights
here at vinnie tube we've already
featured a fair share of them there may
be magical affairs
smash mouth slugfests or simply battles
of wits gone physical however what about
those fights that didn't quite make it
maybe it's due to context the show's
relative lack of popularity or the sheer
number of fights from the very same
series that have more impact than them
some anime fights inevitably fall a bit
under the radar that's what today's
list's about
in this list i hope to introduce to you
some fights that do more than enough
than hold their own among the numerous
memorable moments in anime but need a
little bit more appreciation than what
they
got
[Music]
we start off this list with alfonso
versus leon from garo
2014 was a pretty big year for anime
fights unlimited blade works was airing
seven deadly sins made its debut and
people still had no game no life fresh
in their memories in the midst of all
the craziness going on is for me one of
the best sword fights that flew under
the radar
alfonso versus leon's battle in the
ruins had this whole classic feel to it
while looking like something only made
possible by the wonders of modern
animation technology there's not much
flair or superpower involved in this
fight
at least compared to what you'd expect
but what we have is a good climactic
duel between the two main characters
with some nice musical backdrops
after a furious battle leon and alfonso
charge at one another in an epic final
clash to close out one of the more
under-appreciated fights in that year
before we continue let's take a
momentary break and take a look at the
fastest rising
online anime card game and the sponsors
of this video
xenon zard if it seems familiar to you
perhaps you've heard
of its anime that aired this year
besides looking really good in terms of
visual effects for a mobile game
xenons aren't a freshly released anime
card game that provides a very unique
experience
what experience is that you ask well
it's an ai based game where you not only
play against
but also with ai helpers yes the ai
helps you build decks from the pool of
500 cards in seven categories and the ai
will also chime in and give advice every
time you play an actual game with 16
possible
ai to choose from i'm sure that you can
find the right one for you given how
intricate and deep the gameplay is from
zen onside beginners will really find
the ai a godsend as it guides you
through the three game phases the main
phase
the flash phase and the mana phase the
final one in particular is pretty cool
because this game allows you to exchange
minions and convert them into mana and
the other way around
use the hashtag xenonzad aci on facebook
and twitter in order to meet new friends
or share the game to your community
we've got no time to waste
download xenon from the link now and get
the chance to receive up to 240 of 500
cards during the ongoing events and
campaigns in july don't miss out the
hottest new anime card game in town and
head to the link in the description now
any love for princess principal here
haven't seen a lot of fans and that's a
big shame because the show is really
interesting and it's setting an overall
feel
if you need me to tell you one reason to
watch the series i'd send this fight out
to you i think that not enough people
talk about princess principle but as far
as the fight scenes go it can more than
hold its own
just look at this fight for example this
isn't something that you see every day
i can really feel the impact and the
pace in which everything is happening
all at once there are so many points in
which things can go wrong and we'll end
up with a muddled mess of a fight
but not this time this is a fight that
exceeded all of my expectations when i
first picked up this show
please do check out this show it's worth
every second of your time
they say you can add ufo table to any
series with fight scenes and just sit
back
and watch the magic unfold well i'd say
that the same thing applies to the token
rambu adaptation being a game adaptation
of a rather niche title
at least in japanese social game
standards i'm not surprised that not a
lot of people talked about gotsugeki
token rambu
some fans even ended up with quite a
lukewarm reception to it despite me
having a more positive impression of it
however when we talk about the fight
scenes in particular the final fight
it's a whole different story now i'm
sure many of you who came into this
series blind wanted this there's a lot
going on and reinforcements arriving too
much fanfare i think it's the sound
directing that also helped push this
fight up a notch in my book i just have
a soft spot for epic turns of events in
battles heralded by the opening or the
ending theme blaring in it also gave us
a very touching and dramatic hijikata
scene at the end so what's not to like
about it
[Music]
anyone remember nura rise of the yokai
clan
it's one of the rather underrated shonen
jump series that flew a bit under the
radar i really liked its neat aesthetics
in its traditional japanese backdrop but
once a battle shonen without some cool
fights under its belt for me one of the
fights that doesn't really get talked
about in the fandom as far as i can
recall back then is the one against
tsuchigumo which is surprisingly because
it's such a big progression marker in
the arc for so long our protagonist
rikuo has been a little more than a
punching bag for the spider demon but
with the life of the most trusted
retainer at stake
rikuel gets pushed to take his ability
to the next level and showcase what in
my opinion
is the most beautiful matoy form he
could get throughout the series there
are some more climactic fights in the
series but if i had to throw
something to convince you to give this
anime a watch this would definitely be
the fight for me
is probably not the first title on a lot
of people's minds when they think
boxing anime after all hajime no ippo
exists
however the episode six match between
joe and aragaki blows a lot of anime
fights out of the water
in terms of presentation this fight had
it all it had all the right shots of the
action and the amazing camera angles
that helped enhance an already amazing
fight
this is something that we've come to
expect out of modern anime but that
doesn't make this fight
any less amazing the sound direction is
on point as well not just for the fight
but the entire episode in general it's
superb i also like how the characters
fighting styles also play a part in
deciding the outcome of this competitive
match
overall it's a really great fight that
not enough people talk about
too bad megalo box didn't become as
popular as it should have been
[Music]
whoa whoa what's this a pokemon fight on
a vini tube list
well hear me out for a second okay
pokemon xyz was a big
landmark here for our favorite never
aging protagonist this is where pokemon
as an anime temporarily turned into
legit shown and fair and a lot of people
were completely enthralled with ash's
journey because for the first time he
seemed to be a tiny step away from
winning a pokemon league after
what like two decades well we all know
how that ended up don't we
disappointing results and all with
greninja losing to a pokemon he kind of
had type advantage over but in the midst
of the [ __ ] storm that came as a result
of that people often forgot the fight
ash just had in a match that showcased
the power of ash greninja
greninja tanked multiple grass type
moves on route to winning with his
signature
water shuriken the action was fast and
the battle was a touch and go affair
throughout
i figured earlier that ash would somehow
win the battle with a disadvantage given
that he still has a fated battle ahead
of him in the same tournament but the
way they did it completely impressed me
pokemon might be an anime aimed towards
kids but
every now and then it does give us these
amazing animated and hype fights
i've said a lot of good things about
king's avatar but i just don't think
that he gets talked about enough besides
the story that thoroughly engaged me in
various ways
it also had its fair share of cool
fights here we have an example of an
amazing pvp fight although i doubt that
calling it to fight will give justice to
the gap between the two players
it's more apt to call it a squash a
methodical one in fact
from the get-go you can see yeju just
toying with his opponent
avoiding the incoming attacks through
precision and delivering a slow and
methodical breaking down of dooming's
character he does make an extravagant
show out of it he quickly disappears
but the move is an easy giveaway to the
audience as to who dooming was dealing
with
statement made
tales of zysteria the x is something
quite surprising for me in a sense that
in some ways the anime is actually
better than the game i know at least a
couple of people who share those
sentiments too and i think that a large
part of that's due to how pretty the
entire thing looked
well seeing you for a table makes things
all the more clear if there's anyone who
can elevate an average
entertaining show to the next level it
is of course them isn't it i think that
as far as a video game adaptation goes
this
is one of the best final fights you
could get you have the action
you have the twists and turns in a long
drawn-out fight and you have the
dramatic conclusion i think that my
biggest gripe about this whole affair is
just how it got me wanting more but the
show just ends just like that in a way
this way of not resolving some of the
things that got teased beforehand is
reminiscent of the games in a hilarious
turn of events as far as the fight
itself goes i don't have any complaints
about it and i think that it would do
you a favor to take a look at the full
fight on youtube or something just go
and find it
[Music]
when we say fate we typically think you
for table and the work they put in on
the fate stay night media as a result we
have some other fate fights flying under
the radar one which is this one by all
measures
sig versus ganla is one of the best
fights that fate apocrypha has to offer
but it just gets a little bit
overshadowed by some of the other great
fights even within its series such as
achilles versus chiron
ghana's fight with c gets talked about a
little bit less but in terms of the
explosions and the much anticipated
destructive power
this one does it for me if there's just
any doubt i've got another spot in the
power level chart
this fight just made it all the more
clear the effects were amazing and they
truly showed the magnitude of his power
this is the indian god not even at peak
strength and it already took so many
people to barely take him down
imagine if he didn't get summoned as a
[Music]
lancer
[Music]
lupone 3 is not exactly the first series
you'd think of when we say anime fights
but i think that this one scene just
isn't given enough credit just in case
you need another reminder as to who
among lupon squad is in fact the most
dangerous of them all
look no further than this scene where
goemon destroys the yakuza
single-handedly
it's a one-man army battle for the ages
and our samurai friend simply does what
he does best
slice through the opposition with his
ever powerful katana
the battle is tight it's a lot more
brutal than what we'd expect from lupon
and it features some of the most fluid
animation the series has ever gotten
given the comedic nature of the series
you'd also be surprised at how
overpowered some of these guys really
are and this battle serves as a reality
check
in that regard
there you go with my top 10 underrated
anime fights which anime fights do you
think are underappreciated
type your answers down in the comments
below and we can discuss it over
in such a widespread medium like anime
i'm certain that there are a couple more
fights that you'd find unappreciated for
now we have to leave it at this and i
might decide to do a second volume of
this probably sometime soon say if this
video gets
15 000 likes so leave a like subscribe
and i'll be seeing you next time on
vinnie tube don't forget to check out
our sponsors game
zen zard links in the description
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you